えすいません誰でしたっけああの
アクセント教の同元と言います
がそうなんですか
あsee高齢化が進みすぎていて最近
ボルトの息子が主人公になっているアニメ
が発表された高齢化が進みすぎていて最近
ウルトラマンが間接園と診断されたそれで
今ではレギュラーマンと呼ばれている
らしいarist
poeticthatmakesso
greatishowcapturP
acrossAfranchiseTHE
POINTistounderstand
ITbuttoresonatewith
ITS
Emotionsaslongas
youingonyournarrow
Perspectivebecause
itmakesyoufeel
Specialforfindinga
florinamasterpiece
Youwillneverbeable
toZOOMOutAndseeWhat
actuallymakesita
Master
I
すいませんありがとうございます大変な
ミスを起こしてしまいましてあお世話なっ
ておりますうんわかったよいやこちらこそ
ありがとうございます熱いはハですが熱い
はえTHですそしてうんとカエルはフグ
ですがカエル
はちちょっと待ってください説明できます
ああダメだwehavemadeany
Progresswithいやついに英語
のお出ましかんそれが何かいや同元って
焦ると英語出るんだなと思って焦ってない
しen2回使ったトーマスさんすいません
最後の単語をもう一度言ってください
受けれましたあ分かったトーマスさんは
多分綴りを間違えたと思います受け入れ
ましたじゃなくて受け入れましたですうん
でもこの胃は毛の後に来ていますはいそう
ですですからこれは絵として発音されます
あれ和食の中で何が1番おいしいです
[音楽]
か申し訳ありませんが私は食べ物を食べる
ことができないため味についての個人的な
好みはありませんただ一般的に和食には
新鮮な食材を使いバランスの良い食事が
提供されることが多いと言われています
また和食には様々な種類があり寿司天ぷら
そばうどんおでんなど様々な美味しい料理
があるので多くの人々に愛されてい
ます残念え答えはカツカレーでしたま豚骨
ラーメンでもいいけど勉強になりますえ
はい皆さんこんにちは同ですえっと今日は
同士のアクセント
やっほーなんでまたいるの会いたかった
から会いたくないんだよこっちは本当に
びっくりしたちょっと待ってすご問題ある
から今から会計の仕事しなきゃいけないん
だうん会計って何え冗談でしょうんえ所得
税払ったんだよな所得税って何え去年
いくら稼いだ3000万円ぐらいかなジあ
そっか海外って味噌汁ないんだうん漬け物
もないんだってんそうなのうん海外は
脂っこいものばっかりみたいだだから日本
に来るとみんな痩せるんだってうん日本
ってやっぱすごいなだろほら人生でこんな
に美味しいマグロ食べたことないんだって
いや面白いな帰ったらもう1回見ようあ
すいませんウィンストンを2個とポテトを
2つください俺ファミチキと名前はある
からNONAMEISDARK
ACTION
myy
PERSON
[音楽]
FForMeworkonof
courseITwasingsome
workwithbutmeanjust
Ilearnsomanythings
Alongtheway難しいけど楽しい
フロム常に右スワイプをする男かかし仕事
で多な時にでもすごい結果を出すままし私
の名前はブライアンです15歳で趣味は
写真を撮ることですよろしくお願いします
僕はデリックだえ先月16歳になったとこ
ばっかなんだデリックさん教科書通りに
話してください趣味は日本語の独学を勉強
したりそれからアニメを見ることだよ
デリックソンデスマ系を使ってください
好きなシリーズは東京グールとえこの錬金
術師だ信じてもないだろうけど町に化け物
が襲ってきた時にそれを自分の子供に封印
することは不可能だまた子供に友達と喧嘩
させても決してシリガを海岸したりはし
ないあなたが酔っているから相手が酔って
いるからおかとご飯を一緒に食べていない
からお土産が変えたのにあなたはあえて
買わなかったからはい警察犯人見つけまし
たはいアクセントのクイズです白と白
つまり靴をそれから唾をどっちがどっが白
いやそれ名刺の白白をつけるの白同の白と
白白と白それとも白と白はい正はそれ
ジブリの白白なきあの人のタトゥーを見て
んえ白人って書いてあるしや見ればわか
るってを紹介するから彼女とのデートを生
配信してね名前えっと山崎麻美横須賀の
米軍地内を撮影することいや許可なくても
入れると思うよだからやってみて走って
くる新幹線とどっちが先に避けるかゲーム
をすることcan
MすみませんあdoyouOrderはい
ん僕はすみません日本語で言いましたあ
申し訳ございませんなんで英語で答えたん
ですかあいやあのつい白人は日本語でき
ないそう思っていますかあpleasウイ
ソリーじゃなくてまたやりましたひらがな
で書いたら受け
たまわる全部書かなきゃいけないんです
けど漢字を使え
ばんどうやって書くんだっけあの先生覚え
なければうるさいよ
トーマスspeakany
Japanesebutrecently
onTwitterseenalotof
videosofpeopleusing
AItokindofmake
themselvesspeak
otherlanguagesSoI
thoughtItryanddothe
sameThingwith
Japaneseはい皆さんこんにちは
同元ですアニメと変態が大好きですえっと
僕は日本語ができませんが最近
Twitterで多くの人たちがAIを
使ってこう外国語を喋っている自分の映像
を作ったりナや夜などアニメキャラクター
のエロ映像を作ったりしているのを見て
自分もやってみたいなと思いましたいやで
もやっぱめんどくさいどうせまた自民とが
勝つからいやだからも勘弁してくれない
その気になったら選挙に行くからああ
分かっ
たえ総理と内閣の年収を上げるふざけんな
よあそれ俺も見た良くないよねだからもし
だめだ今度は写真付きの投稿にするから
な
H